[MUSIC PLAYING]
Jobberman.com is currently
the largest job website
in sub-Saharan Africa.
When we started Jobberman,
of course structurally when
you look at the labor
markets in Nigeria
and also the rest of
Africa, you discover
that it's a candidate
longer market.
So you have a lot of
candidates with respect
to the number of jobs.
So initially when
we started, there
was definitely more traction
from the job seeker side.
And over time, companies
started approaching us,
because eventually where you
have the talent, definitely
the employers will gravitate
towards that platform.
So it was initially more scaled
towards the job seeker side,
and then gradually we started
building some traction
on the employer side.
In terms of vastness,
there are a lot
of countries on the continent.
But we also know that we
are very limited in terms
of our ability to be able
to execute very well.
So we are definitely
very selective in terms
of the country we
try and take on.
We also understand that in order
to be able to win in Africa,
we don't really have to have
a physical presence on the 53
countries.
We rather prefer to be the best
and to be maybe the biggest
in terms of our placement
than to grow very thin
and be in 53 countries
in Africa without being
able to have the impact we were
trying to have at the moment.